ça a commencé par des brimades sur mon
poids en classe je recevais des stylos
des coups de combat dans le dos je me
prenais des gifles et des insultes
pendant 6 ans je n'ai parlé à personne
j'avais trop honte j'avais trop peur et
puis j'ai décidé d'en finir j'ai acheté
un litre d'alcool à brûler je l'ai
répondu sur mes vêtements et je me suis
mis le feu j'avais 16 ans ces mots sont
ceux de Jonathan destin victimes devenu
figure de la lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire décédé en août dernier et dont
je veux ici saluer la mémoire et le
combat ces drames individuels sont aussi
des drames collectifs le suicide de
l'Insee qui a mis fin à ses jours à
l'âge de 13 ans en étant je veux en
notre nom à tous lui rendre hommage et
adresser nos condoléances à sa famille
et à ses amis mais aussi lui adresser
nos excuses parce que ses enfants sont
nos enfants Lucas Thibault Chanel ou
Dina ils ont mis fin à leur jour à l'âge
de 10 ans 13 ans ou 14 ans pour que le
harcèlement cesse ses enfants se sont
nos enfants Les enfants de la République
qui aurait dû les protéger nous tous le
harcèlement est un fléau qui mine le
quotidien de milliers de jeunes et
causent trop souvent des drames la
détresse la dépression est parfois même
le suicide
le décès de Lindsay en est un terrible
exemple et je veux ici dire toute ma
solidarité et mon soutien à sa famille
et à ses amis
nous allons faire de la lutte contre le
harcèlement la priorité absolue de la
rentrée 2023 nous allons étendre le
programme phare au lycée nous allons
désigner dès la rentrée dans chaque
collège un adulte référent dans la lutte
contre le harcèlement nous allons
protéger davantage les élèves victimes
en primaire en ouvrant par décret la
possibilité d'écarter d'une école un
élève auteur de harcèlement nous
rendrons obligatoire la formation des
personnels contre le harcèlement nous
augmenterons les moyens des plateformes
d'alerte et d'écoute enfin j'ai demandé
au ministre de l'intérieur de la justice
et du numérique d'appuyer le ministre de
l'éducation nationale afin d'être plus
efficace dans la prévention et les
sanctions contre le harcèlement
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux